one of the things i liked about
the star wars franchise that you guys
did was that the creative handoff
between you and ryan johnson which i
felt
you know it was letting filmmakers take
their own stories and take
take the story where they wanted to go
and i felt that played out in a really
interesting way
but i know not everyone feels that way
and i'm curious for you as the person
who helped get that foundation off the
ground and also concluded it
do you feel like that trilogy would have
benefited from planning out a very
strict
three movie story from the very
beginning or do you
enjoy that kind of creative freedom to
kind of take the characters different
ways and kind of see how it goes
you know i i've been involved in a
number of
projects that have been um
uh you know in most case
series that have
ideas that begin the thing where you
feel like you know where it's gonna go
and then sometimes it's an actor who
comes in
uh other times it's a relationship that
as it's written doesn't quite work and
things that you think are gonna just
you know uh be so well received um
just crash and burn and other things
that you think like oh that's a little
small moment that's a
one-episode character suddenly become a
hugely important
part of the the story and i feel like
what i've learned as a
lesson a few times now and it's
something that that in
especially in this pandemic
year uh working with writers
the lesson is that you know you you have
to plan things the best you can
and and you always need to be able to
respond to the unexpected and the
unexpected can come
in all sorts of forms and i just i do
think that
uh you know there's
there's nothing more important than
knowing where you're going and
there are projects that i've worked on
where we had some ideas but we
we hadn't worked through them enough we
had some sometimes we had some ideas
but then we weren't allowed to do them
the way we wanted to we had
i mean i've had all sorts of situations
where um
you know uh you you plan things
in a certain way and you suddenly find
yourself doing something that's 180
degrees
different um and then sometimes it works
really well
and you feel like wow that really came
together and other times you think oh my
god
i can't believe this is where we are and
sometimes when it's not working out it's
because it's what you planned
and other times when it's not working
out it's because it didn't it's like you
just you
you never really know but but having a
plan you know i have learned in some
cases the hard way
um is the most you know critical thing
because otherwise
you don't know what you're setting up
you don't know what you're
you know uh what to emphasize because if
you don't know the inevitable
of the story you know you're just as
good as your
last you know sequence or or
effect or joke or whatever but you want
to be leading to something inevitable